foreign
YouTube channel in today's video we are
going to be talking about the Google
Keyword Planner a tool that will help
you putting together your Google ads
campaign or it can also help you in
deciding for your keywords for your
search engine optimization we will talk
about what is Google Keyword Planner how
do you use it and how what are the
benefits of it and how can you sort of
bypass some of its shortcomings I am
Mark campman I'm your digital navigator
for this video and before we start if
you like the video click the like button
and of course if you want to subscribe
to our YouTube channel then click Below
on the Subscribe button right so let
these start by giving you some
interesting stats about Google
advertising Google is the Undisputed
market leader when it comes to digital
advertising their market share is over
80 percent followed by Bing Yahoo and
Yandex now 63 percent of people who are
online they do click on Google ads and
you may hear that people always say I
never click on ads but people actually
do and a lot of those ads are actually
on mobile
33 of mobile ad spending goes actually
to Google
so Google's ad Revenue in the third
quarter in 2022 was 54 billion US
dollars yeah that is an annual revenue
of over 200 billion dollars which is a
staggering amount
the beauty about advertising on mobile
or in on the on desktop is that it gives
you an immediate sort of payback yeah
therefore the Gen PPC generates twice as
many visitors than for instance search
engine optimization does but PPC costs
money compared to SEO does not cost
money other than your own time and
resources
so Google advertising is there it's
there to stay and it is one of the major
channels that you should be using for
reaching out to your audiences
so let's then have a look at one of the
most important tools that Google makes
available to help you with putting
together your advertising campaigns
which is the Google Keyword Planner yep
so and by the way if you want to know
Google Keyword Planner is a free tool
yep so you don't have to buy it it is
embedded in the Google ads tool that
Google has and it will I will show you
later in the demo how to access it and
how to use it
so here are the topics that we will be
talking about in this video we're going
to be talking about what is Google
planner we'll look at imported terms
related to Google Keyword Planner we'll
look at some of the features of Google
Keyword Planner and then I will be
giving you a demo of how to use Google
Keyword Planner
um what are the best parts of Google
Keyword Planner and how can you bypass
some of its shortcomings and then I will
close the presentation with some tips
and tricks on Google Keyword Planner
so before we go into Google Keyword
Planner let's talk about keywords yeah
keywords we use them everywhere and they
shave as the foundation of nearly every
marketing campaign that we launch online
whether you're deploying Google ads
cleaning up content for SEO helping your
products to be found on Amazon
keywords are at the heart of how you
connect with your customers or your
ideal prospects so they are used for
pay-per-click and for SEO purposes
in the context of an SEO campaign a
keyword is a phrase a query that a
Searcher types into the browser to prove
to get a list of results examples of SEO
keywords could include words like
accounting software QuickBooks for
self-employed workers or online
bookkeeping Solutions
now PPC keywords are used for your
advertising like Google ads your ad you
add a keywords to your Google ads setup
to help determine when and where your ad
should appear
yep so somebody types in a query Google
matches that query with ads that contain
that query yep and then with various
calculations it will show the ads that
best answers the query so a great
keyword list can help improve the
performance of your ads and help you to
avoid a high price to pay for your ads
poor keywords can ultimately cause you
to have higher price to pay for your ads
and lower at positions
so at the beginning of any SEO or PPC
campaign you should plan to invest time
to do your keyword research much of this
process can be automated and Google
Keyword Planner is a fantastic tool that
can help you with that but remember in
the end it's still humans who need to
look over the list to properly determine
the keyword relevance
so let's have a look at some of the
features of Google Keyword Planner and
what Google Keyword Planner actually is
so Google Keyword Planner is a tool that
helps advertisers find the right
keywords to Target for their Google ad
campaigns
yeah it helps you research the keywords
for your search campaigns and you can
also discover new keywords related to
your business you could identify your
competitors keywords and get ideas
around the keywords that your
competitors are using additionally
Google Keyword Planner will give you
volumes estimates of the searches that
those keywords receive and the cost you
would potentially pay when you use those
keywords in your advertising campaign
yeah so Google Keyword Planner allows
you to see how often certain keywords
are searched for on Google and it
provides data of the cost of running the
ads for those keywords so you get also
suggestions for related keywords is
great if you don't really know where to
start as far as finding keywords for
your ad so very important to know that
Google also provides the average cost
for your ads to show on searches for a
keyword so it's easier to pick and chose
choose which keywords best suit your
strategy and your budget
so Google keywords planner is a useful
tool for identifying the most effective
keywords to use in your ad campaign and
as I said before as well for estimating
the potential cost and reach of a
campaign
so knowing how frequently keywords in
your industry are searched for is
extremely important for your campaign
because you wouldn't want to Target
keywords that no one is using but you
also want to Target keywords that have a
ridiculously high search volume because
they tend to be more competitive and
when they are more competitive you will
have to pay a higher price to Target
those keywords so to summarize Google
Keyword Planner helps you discover new
Search keywords
it shows you average monthly search
numbers for those keywords it helps you
to determine the cost and it helps you
to create new search ad campaigns so all
in all a very powerful tool that you can
use for your Google ad campaigns which
is also completely integrated with
Google ads so the keyword list that you
create in Google Keyword Planner you can
then bring directly into your Google ads
campaign setup
so here are some important terms related
to Google Keyword Planner
so there is keywords of course keywords
now what is a keyword a keyword is a
word or a phrase that users type into a
search engine to find information on a
particular topic from an end user
perspective you could say it's a query
yeah and advertisers use those keywords
to Target their ads to users who are
searching for specific products or
services or have questions around
problems that they have now search
volume is the number of times a
particular keyword is search for on
Google over a certain period of time so
Keyword Planner provides you data on
search volume to help you understand how
popular certain keywords are match type
refers to the way in which a keyword
will trigger an ad Google offers several
different match types like broad match
phrase match and exact match it goes
from exact match where Google will
actually only look at the exact word or
phrase that you specified as a keyword
compared to Broad match where it will
look at a much broader sort of range
keywords in relation to the search term
that you defined in your Google ads
setup
an ad group is the container for your
keywords yeah it's a set of keywords
that are related to a specific theme or
topic so ad groups are used to organize
and structure your ad campaign and each
ad group can have its own sets of ads
and targeting options in relation to the
keywords that you specified keywords can
be negative as we say yeah so negative
keywords is a word or phrase that Google
will not show an ad for in when it comes
to certain share search queries yes so
it have helped you to avoid wasting
Impressions on irrelevant searches and
thereby it improves the relevance of
your ads so if your keyword is
accounting because you're selling
accounting software you don't want
people who search for accounting jobs
yet to see your ad because they will not
be interested in buying your accounting
software so you can specify jobs as a
negative keyword as I said earlier
Google Keyword Planner will also give
you traffic estimate traffic estimates
are estimates of the potential reach and
cost of an ad campaign based on the
selected keywords and Keyword Planner
provides those traffic estimates to help
you with your budget setting and
targeting options for your campaign
there are important metrics as well that
are related to Google Keyword Planner
and therefore of course also related to
Google ads a cost per click is the
amount that you will pay each time a
user clicks on your ads yeah that's why
we call Google ads pay-per-click
advertising you're not paying paying
Yeah by default you're not paying on
when people see your ads you will pay
when people click on your ads and of
course what you want to know for your
campaign what is the average cost per
click
you also want to know what the
click-through rate for your campaign is
that is a ratio of the number of times
an ad was clicked in comparison to the
number of times it was shown and that
expressed as a percentage so two
important indicators cost per click and
click-through rate
finally there is a very important term
is what we call long tail keywords
yeah they are more specific keyword
phrases that visitors are more likely to
use when they're closer to a point of
purchase
yes so a normal keyword can be dog food
yeah you see it has a very high search
volume which means the higher the search
volume the more likely you will pay a
higher cost per click because the
competition is very high for those
keywords yes so what brands do what what
companies do is actually they step away
from the intense competition on the
long-term keyword or the the short-term
keywords like dog food and they move to
longer term keywords like how to make
dog food at home
it gives you a lower search volume but
the chance that people will engage with
you on your ads is bigger because they
are closer to that point of purchase
okay so those are long tail keywords
right so let's have a look at some of
the Keyword Planner features
so to summarize yeah Google Keyword
Planner gives you search volume data for
keywords once you put a keyword in you
get that volume data but it will also
give you ideas for keyword yep and it
will actually automatically group those
ideas for you in potential ad groups
that you can use it will then give you
traffic estimates and you can say use
filters as well to make your keyword
list more specific right
so let's have a look at how Google
Keyword Planner works yeah and it's
important to understand that before you
can use Google Keyword Planner you will
need to have a Google ad account rep and
unique can create that by going to
Google ad you will have to put in your
credit card or debit cards yeah but as
long as you're not publishing any
campaigns you won't get charged by
Google so there's no risk for you to
when you enter your credit card details
okay and then when you're in and I'll
show you in a minute where you can find
it then you just start entering your
keywords and then Google Keyword Planner
will do the rest for you
so let's have a look at how Google
Keyword Planner works first of all we
need to go to Google ads so let's type
in Google ads and I assume yeah or the
fact is you will need a um a Google ads
account to be able to access Google
Keyword Planner so when I sign into my
Google ads account I click here on the
account that I want to use for this demo
and this takes me to the Google ads
interface
so this is of course a different topic
to talk about Google ads which we will
do in other videos for now it is
important to find out where do I find
Google a Keyword Planner and how do I
access it so when you click here in the
top on tools and settings
you will hear see all the tools that you
have available for planning for your
shared library for bulk actions for
measurements setting up your Google ads
billing for your Google ads but here
under the planning you see Keyword
Planner and that takes you straight to
the Google Keyword Planner so here is
the interface so here you see plans that
you've created for keywords yes so you
can save your keywords into ad groups
you can save those ad groups into plans
and what you can then do is import those
plans as it were in your Google ads
campaign but what we're particularly
interested in for now is how do I
discover new keywords and how do I get
search volumes and forecasts those are
the two areas where you can get data
about your keywords so let's start with
looking at Discover the keywords so here
you go and there's two ways to find
keywords you can start with keywords you
can also start with a website so what
you do here you put in the keywords that
you want to look for so I can here put
for instance SEO
I can put in link building
and I can put in a keyword research
and click on that
yep so I can unfiltered unrelated
keyword I can put that in and entering a
site so I can make it as specific as
possible but let's go for these three
keywords
get the results
yeah and here you see my three keywords
and here you see a whole range of
keyword ideas
yeah and that is very of course Very
powerful very useful information these
are all words in relation to my three
words that I specified SEO link building
and keyword research
now what is the data it will give you
the average monthly searches you see
that here in bands from 10K to 100k from
1K to 10K it will give you the
competition level for the keywords now
bear in mind this is competition level
for Google pay-per-click advertising it
is not a competition level for the
actual keyword so
um yep and then here you see the top of
page bit the low range and here you see
the top of bit high range
yes so that is kind of the interface
here you have your keyword view you can
specify your columns you can exclude
ideas in this case add all suggestions
and here you can add filters and here
you can refine your keywords and we're
going to have a look at that in a minute
yep here you can specify the country
yep so we've got United Kingdom you can
say where do you want to search for and
here you put in the period and that is
in this case January to December 2022 so
that is sort of the high level interface
when it comes to getting ideas for
keywords so let's go back and do a bit
more
details on this yes so let me take a
word like t-shirt t-shirt and what are
the ideas that I'm getting and I click
here get results so here now I'm getting
a whole range of ideas
yeah on keywords
so now there may be keywords that I
don't want in here yeah so this is where
I can specify and refine my keywords so
here I can say do Branch or non-branded
so I don't want any keywords in relation
to specific Brands so I can take those
out yes so your Nike keywords are gone
yes so your Adidas keywords are gone so
it is a lot more specific now
yes so you can also say for instance I
don't want t-shirts with no I don't want
Playboy t-shirts yeah so what I can do I
can go to filters I can add a filter and
here I can say exclude
in this case keyword text does not
contain white for instance yep so that
will means it will take all the t-shirts
out where the word white comes in
yep so that is how you can get your
speed more specific with your keywords
and filter them to be more specific and
more relevant for you all right so what
you can then do you can actually select
a few of the keywords that you say hey
these are relevant for me and you can
say okay I am going to put them in a
plan I can put them in an existing plan
or I can put them in a new plan I can
put them into an ad group yep or I can
also look at the match type for those
keywords yeah so I can put them as broad
match phrase match and exact match and
then I can add keywords to create my
plan okay I can copy the keywords
there's more that I can do I can add
them as negative keywords yeah so those
are kind of the functionalities that you
have when you search for your keywords
so let's have a look now at do a bit
more on your keywords when it comes to
competition and when it comes to long
tail so let's close this let's do a
search on keywords for the term e-bike
yep so I'm going to get my results
and what I want to do I want to look for
the keyword with a low competition
yeah so here you see the high
competition and the low competition I
can sort them going up and going down
yes I'm going to so it's a low
and now remember this competition is for
ads yeah so this is not competition for
your search engine optimization
yes so here when you look at low
competition keywords look at this one
you have stealth bomber e-bike here you
see that is a very popular keyword with
low competition which has a year on year
change of 900 percent
yeah so that is how you can find your
trending keywords yeah so this could be
a very relevant keyword for you yep so
there is also your three months change
so you can look at seasonal keywords
so I can also search for the term for
instance holiday sweater
get results
yeah and if I now look at my three
months change I can look at seasonal
keywords here so look at this pool and
Bear Christmas sweater holiday sweater
ugly Christmas sweater yeah funny so
here you see the shredders specifically
when it comes to to seasonal patterns so
important that you identify those as
well
yeah now how do you find lucrative
keywords you're going to look at the top
of page bit Yeah and see if they have a
commercial value so what you do is
you're going to look at the top of page
bit high range yeah and from low so here
you see we go back to high range
yep so here you see that these terms
like the Bowden Christmas sweater has a
fairly high top of page price yeah so a
bit price which means there is a good
commercial value for this sweater which
also means that you could then use that
for your SEO because a lot of people
will be searching for that keyword so
there's a high commercial value and that
is good for your
organic ranking so lots of features that
you can get here out of your Google
Keyword Planner
okay so now that you've understand the
basics of Google Keyword Planner let's
have a look at some tips that will give
you more functionality in the Google
Keyword Planner so one of the big issues
that I have with Google Keyword Planner
is the fact that my average monthly
searches are in a range between here for
example
ebook I didn't want ebook I wanted
e-bike
yeah so that this is range of between 10
and 100
000 average monthly searches now that
range is so wide that doesn't do
anything for me so how can I bring exact
average monthly searches into my Google
Keyword Planner now there's two ways of
doing that the first way of doing that
is go to the forecast section for the
with the word e-bike for instance yep
and I'm going to add a keyword and I'm
going to type e-bike
yep I'm going to add the keyword to the
ad Group which is test I'm clicking
create and I'm going to save my keyword
now here you see what the details is
that you get here so I can get based on
this data uh here you see the average
cost per acquisition number of clicks
but what I want to do here I want to
look at not the maximize conversions but
I want to look at the maximize clicks
and I'm going to apply that
yeah I'm going to put it into a slightly
bigger
um let's have a look here yeah so here I
have the data so here you see I can get
two conversions
440 pounds with a five per pound average
daily budget now what I'm gonna do here
I'm going to click on the highest price
the highest budget that I would spend of
this of let's say 520 and let's see how
that changes my data so then here you
see that with this highest price
for the term e-bike yeah I can get about
000 impressions
and because I took the highest price
that would be giving me the highest
number impressions of Impressions so I
could say that on average the e-bike for
this period the monthly number of
Impressions that you would get would be
thirty thousand yeah so that is a way to
get more exact search volumes for your
keywords
another way of getting average monthly
search details is by using an external
tool called keyword everywhere keyword
everywhere is basically for Google
search so if I type in e-bike here in
Google search it will give me
search volumes here in under the Search
terms and I can see additional keywords
as well but once I've activated it
yeah so I'm going to switch it on yeah
so to get these details I can now go
back to my keyword ideas if I do a
refresh
because I've activated the Google Chrome
plugin I go back to discover new
keywords I type in ebike I'm getting the
results and see what I'm getting now I'm
getting exact volumes I'm getting cost
per click I'm getting competition and I
get trends for that keyword or those
keywords as well so this all of a sudden
adds a lot of value to your Google
Keyword Planner when it comes to the
monthly search volumes so a very
powerful tool now it basically works on
the basis of credits that you buy each
keyword that it shows you the search
volumes is costing you one credit
yeah and you buy hundred thousand
credits for ten dollars that basically
gives you one hundred thousand keywords
as part of your research so it is a good
deal I think to get the credits for your
keyword everywhere too
okay so that is how to unlock search
volumes in Google Keyword Planner let's
look at the let me switch it off to go
back to the core functionality switching
off keywords everywhere let's do a
refresh yeah so we're going to discover
new ideas we're going back to the e-bike
and we're gonna see that I can make my
search results local yeah with the local
Dimension so here I can type United
Kingdom but I can make my locations more
specific so I can also say for instance
let's do London yes so I now have United
Kingdom and London so I'm going to take
United Kingdom out and I now have
london-based search volumes yep so
that's what you can get by changing the
location I'm going to look at the
popularity of search locations so I'm
going to look at forecasts I'm going to
let's say ADD test is the keyword the ad
group here I'm going to type in Super
Bowl okay I'm going to click save and
I'm going to change the location to the
United States okay and don't need the
United Kingdom so I'm going to click
save
yeah so here I'm getting my conversion
data but if I scroll down then here you
can see what are the top states when it
comes to using that keywords
yep so that is a really powerful way to
look at
locations you could also be even more
specific I can hear say okay give me zip
codes for instance here so you can
search by ZIP codes as well and you can
see how the popularity is around zip
code
so finally what you can do here as well
is to look at the various devices that
people are using for those Search terms
okay so that is it what I want to share
with you on Google Keyword Planner
you've seen the basic operation and I
also gave you some ways to get
additional functionality and
particularly ways to get more detailed
search volumes
so now that you've seen all the ins and
outs of Google Keyword Planner its
functionality and how to overcome some
of its shortcomings let's close with
giving you some tips and tricks on using
Google Keyword Planner first of all make
sure you use Broad and specific match
types when you enter your keywords to
get as wider range of keywords possible
in your in your keyword lists also make
sure that you research your competition
just go to enter the website of your
competition and see what keywords come
up with that your competitors may be
using that you have forgotten so you can
then take those keywords and get
additional keyword ideas around those
keywords that your competition is using
make use of negative keywords I
explained negative keywords earlier yeah
keywords like jobs like free like
promotion yeah filter those out in your
in your keyword lists so you have the
best sort of Clicks in your Google ads
Google Keyword Planner is not the only
tool combine your keyword data with
other tools like semrush or HH refs and
like the keywords everywhere tool that I
explained to you and how that can enrich
the data you have in your Google Keyword
Planner and then finally experiment with
different keywords and AD groups while
you're running your campaign Google will
give you campaign results it will give
you suggestions it will give you the
most popular keywords that people are
using so every time check your campaign
settings and your ad groups and your
keywords and you may want to fine tune
those
right so that's a wrap thank you for
your time and I hope you enjoyed this
session about Google Keyword Planner
more to come if you like the video don't
forget to click the like button and if
you want to subscribe to the simply
learned YouTube channel click the
Subscribe button below that's it for now
I wish you a great day and see you at
the next video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here